what is up everybody it's anna mack here
for anime uproar and wow the mha manga
just dropped a freaking bombshell on all
of us all for one seems to have secretly
stolen the most broken quirk in mha
allowing him to literally turn back time
jakku finally returns and the first one
for all user yoichi warns him of an
imminent attack and endeavour gets even
more incredible character development is
this going to be endeavor's greatest
victory or is this going to be his death
we have to talk about it it was so crazy
so let's get into it you guys know how
this works leave a quick like and
comment right now it helps us out a lot
and it only takes a second and of course
subscribing and hitting that
notification bell is a completely free
way of directly supporting the channel
you can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram at animeopror finally this
video will of course contain boku no
hero manga spoilers so please proceed
with caution you have been warned okay
right off the bat i have to issue
another correction when i was making my
previous chapter review i was going off
the unofficial translation as opposed to
the official viz.com translation now
while i do always read the vis.com
translation it takes me several days to
make a video so if i waited for the
official translation i would have to
publish the video many days later and i
know that a lot of you guys wouldn't
want to wait that long usually both the
official and unofficial translations
match up very closely but last week
there was a big mistranslation in the
unofficial that we need to talk about
during that endeavor childhood flashback
the unofficial translation stated that
he witnessed a man trying to rescue his
daughter from a villain but failing and
dying along with the daughter as
endeavour watched in horror that is
traumatic enough in itself but the
official translation confirmed that it
was actually even worse
this was not some random guy that
endeavour saw trying to save someone
this was actually endeavour's own father
trying to save an innocent girl from a
villain so when he was a teenager
endeavour witnessed his own father die
right before his eyes in a failed rescue
attempt
now this doesn't take anything away from
the analysis i made of endeavour's
character in my previous chapter review
if anything this only adds to what i
said because it goes even further in
terms of explaining how endeavour came
to be the type of father that he
eventually became this gives us an even
better explanation for why he became so
obsessed with becoming the strongest and
surpassing almighty endeavor didn't want
to suffer the same fate as his father
and he didn't want his children to have
to go through what he went through he
believed that he would be weak and
vulnerable until the day that he
surpassed all might and he believed that
his own family and children would always
be in danger until he finally achieved
that goal and so this fear of sharing
his father's fate and putting his own
children through the same trauma that he
suffered through as a kid is what drove
his obsession and that is what
ultimately turned him into the terrible
father that he became even though his
main goal was actually to protect his
family man i said it before and i'll say
it again endeavor is by far the best
written character in mha and it's not
even close despite being an overpowered
superhero and the strongest pro hero in
japan he is so flawed so human and so
real horikoshi did an absolutely
phenomenal job with this man's character
arc and i can't wait to see where things
go from here speaking of which let's see
where things went from here in the
latest chapter of the story with his
mask destroyed and with endeavour
ruthlessly attacking him all for one is
struggling to defend himself he still
appears to be using a shield quirk to
keep his body from disintegrating under
the force of endeavour's attacks but it
doesn't look like he'll be able to hold
out for much longer all for one didn't
think that endeavor would be capable of
making him relive the humiliation of
losing to all might but as was the case
with all might there is nothing more
dangerous than a wounded hero and
endeavour is proving that with his
relentless attacks with the help of
hawks's feathers endeavor is able to
increase his speed and smash all for one
with a vanishing jet burn which sets
almost the entire battlefield on fire
the other heroes who were on the ground
are forced to flee the area as the
battle between endeavour and all for one
spirals out of control endeavour is
hoping to finish all for one off with a
prominent burn attack but the amount of
times he can use this overpowered attack
is limited so endeavor has to break
through all of all for one's defenses
first using physical attacks before
going in for the finisher hawks is
impressed with the fact that endeavour
is being smart and using strategy again
and he says he's glad that endeavour
managed to regain his composure after
going berserk earlier but endeavor
responds by saying that he is not
composed at all his blood is boiling and
he is as angry as he has ever been but
this time he plans to use that anger and
that emotion to his advantage meanwhile
comey woods warns everyone to evacuate
immediately as endeavour smashes over
one to the ground and then rushes him
attacking wildly and chipping away at
all from one's shield as a man who uses
a wood-based quirk you better believe
that kamui knows he has to get out of
there before the fire consumes
everything and he probably saved some
lives with his quick timing both hero
lives and villain lives so props to
kamui endeavour then grabs all for one
and begins dragging him across the
battlefield leaving nothing but fire and
destruction in his wake since they are
now in close contact all for one
attempts to grab endeavor and steal his
quirk
but endeavour pulls a homelander and
blasts all for one's hand with beams of
fire that emerge from his eyes endeavour
says that the only thing all for once
hand has ever done is destroy people's
lives but all for one tries to reverse
uno him by saying that he destroyed
lives as well endeavor doesn't even try
to deny it and he says that toya aka
dabi is a product of his own mistakes so
this means that endeavour must take
responsibility for all of the lives that
toya has taken and destroyed and even
though endeavour can't change the past
he is determined to use the painful
lessons of the past to carve out a
better future for his children and all
the other heroes endeavour is determined
to prevail in this battle so that the
past sins of his generation don't ruin
the future of the next generation in
that moment we see what looks like an
image of the class 1a students as adults
and although we don't get to see them up
close we do see some cool features like
deku having a new long cape and bakugou
apparently wearing two viking-esque
braids in his hair or maybe they're not
viking braids maybe they're like gall
braids like in asterix and obelix anyway
endeavor is prepared to sacrifice
everything and bear all of the
responsibility and all of the punishment
but he refuses to lose this fight no
matter what because he is determined to
keep looking over his sons and helping
them find a way towards a better future
and also presumably his daughter as well
because he also has a daughter as
endeavour pledges to keep on hating
himself because that hate is what feeds
his rage and his power he grabs all for
one in his arms flies him into the sky
and literally burns him to ashes like
seriously all for one's body turns
completely black and begins to
disintegrate into ashes and it looks
like over one has finally been destroyed
an exhausted endeavor is convinced that
all for one is dead and that he can't
possibly survive this but hawks warns
him to back away we then hear all for
one's voice which is messed up in and of
itself because this dude should
definitely be dead over one asks
endeavor whether he really believed that
he would be defeated so easily and that
he didn't have a trick up his sleeve
even though this old body is now
expendable for all for one because he is
also possessing shigaraki's fancy new
body he still wanted to use this body to
try something out
we then see a panel that shows little
eddie and the quirk destroying bullets
that had been made using her blood and
then in the very next panel we see that
all for one's body is seemingly
rebuilding itself from the ashes more
accurately it seems to be rewinding
itself to a state before he had been
injured by all might and i know this
because we see that an eye has appeared
on his face even though all for one
didn't have eyes before endeavor reduced
him to ashes all for one proclaims that
heroes are not the only ones who are
willing to risk their lives in battle
and the chapter text tells us that just
like heroes villains are also the most
dangerous when they are wounded as this
insanity is happening we finally see a
glimpse of deku after like 7 or 8
chapters
he is still traveling over the ocean and
suddenly the first user one for all
yoichi manifests behind deku and tells
him that he has a bad feeling he seems
to sense that something bad just
happened or is about to happen deku then
realizes that something is flying
towards him and the narrator states that
a mysterious threat is drawing near now
all we see are multiple small dots that
seem to be flying towards deku but what
are these dots and how did they locate
deku as he is soaring over some random
spot in the ocean off the coast of japan
are they flying nomu are they other
flying villains are they some sort of
military squadron whatever this is it's
definitely serious enough to worry both
deku and yoichi although yoichi may have
actually been reacting to what all for
one and just did it is not 100 clear
what exactly yoichi was reacting to but
it is possible that he has some sort of
special connection to his brother so he
knew that all for one just pulled off
something insane speaking of which by
showing us that panel of eddie and the
quirk destroying bullets horikoshi is
heavily implying that all for one
somehow got his hands on eddie's
insanely overpowered time reversing
quirk called rewind unless horikoshi is
trying to deliberately mislead us with
the airy panel then we have to assume
that all for one found a way to clone
rewind using the samples of aries blood
and dna that were located within the
quirk destroying bullets we know that
shigaraki stole some of those bullets
from chisaki so all for one definitely
had access to aries blood even though he
didn't have direct access to her wait
does this mean that the woman with the
white hair inside of all for one really
was airy it really was her vestige
rebelling against all for one if he
managed to clone her quirk using her
blood and dna that might actually have
been her vestige which is just freaking
insane and in case anyone needs a
reminder aries quirk rewind is a top
contender for the most broken and
overpowered quirk of all time it can
instantly murder someone by rewinding
them out of existence or it could
instantly heal someone by rewinding them
to a time before they were injured and
if that wasn't overpowered enough some
have speculated that once rewind is
fully awakened it could literally rewind
all of humanity back to the stone age
the crazy thing about rewind is that
everything we've seen from it so far
came from a little girl who has very
little control of her quirk and who
clearly hasn't tapped into its full
potential now imagine a villain who has
the experience of using hundreds of
different quirks successfully taking
control of rewind the implications here
are just staggering if this really is
what's happening right now if all for
one has rewind then the only way he can
be stopped is if his quirks rebel
against him again on the inside honestly
i just don't see endeavour hawks and the
other heroes beating him if he can
rewind his body back to its prime
i'll be real with you guys i didn't see
this twist with all for one coming to me
it kind of looked like endeavour was
about to kill all for one as part of his
epic redemption arc but of course all
for one's story wouldn't be over yet
because he was still possessing
shigaraki's body so endeavour would get
a big w but the story would go on and
shigaraki slash all for one would remain
the main villain however horikoshi seems
to be flipping the script on us so we
might actually see endeavour dying as
part of his redemption arc rather than
winning to be fair that could also be an
incredible finale to his character arc
if handled properly although i'm
definitely kind of rooting for endeavour
now after everything he's gone through
what do you guys think is endeavour
going to die or is he going to kill all
for one speaking of all for one does he
now have rewind was that really ares
vestige inside of him in the previous
chapter and if so what does all this
mean for the final war arc
finally what is the threat that is
suddenly approaching deku since
shigaraki all for one and dobby are
presumably busy elsewhere who is coming
after deku is it other villains using
flying nomu is it some military squadron
don't forget to leave your thoughts down
in the comments below you guys know the
drill if you enjoyed this video and you
want to see more in the future leave
that quick like and comment it's free it
takes only a second but it helps us so
much with the youtube algorithm and of
course don't forget to subscribe and hit
the notification bell to join the space
fam you can also hit us up on twitter
and instagram at anime opera i want to
give a big thank you to all of our anime
outpour patrons for making videos like
this one possible special thank you to
kyle salisbury this man is an absolute
mad lad and a disciple of lord twigo
himself and i can't forget all of our
the one tier patrons the ones who rise
above all other clans including alpha
sigma pate heffa the red-haired fox
hinokami and water the toasted chi corey
mcgowan the fallen chosen orihime wukong
dante tinnell and baked buddhist finally
thank you also to our pro hero tier
patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh angel cruz alicia octor bonnie
parks fat boy games kaido might be a
duck alivania and anime s codem if you
guys enjoy our videos and you feel that
they provide value to you consider
supporting us on patreon as always thank
you guys so much for watching and until
next time see ya space cowboys